alors ce rassemblement se fait dans une
volonté d'avoir un maximum de
représentants de la gauche après avec un
parti une étiquette partie sans
étiquette partie c'était pas c'était pas
là l'essentiel l'essentiel c'était la
reconnaissance des qualités de chacun
pour pouvoir porter cette cette fibre
sociale
auprès auprès des gens c'est un
département qui a suffisamment de
richesses pour qu'il s'interroge sur la
répartition de ces richesses et que une
partie de ces richesses puisse être
destinée au développement et à la
réponse aux besoins qui se sont des
besoins sociaux éducatifs ou
d'aménagement ou des besoins écologiques
sur notre canton